bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
l'actu sur tv fil 78 le journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres de
ce lundi 9 décembre 2013
une délégation unitaire du patronat des
yvelines face au préfet se battant pour
faire part de la situation difficile des
artisans et entrepreneurs les
représentants dans le département de la
confédération générale du patronat des
petites et moyennes entreprises et de la
fédération française du bâtiment
viendront nous en dire plus sans plateau
cinq commerces ravagé par le feu 55
pompiers mobilisés dimanche matin à
plaisir dans le quartier des gâtines le
réveil a été difficile pour les
commerçants et riverains le 25e téléthon
s'est achevée dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche avec un total de 78 millions de
promesses de dons au niveau national les
premiers chiffres dans les yvelines et
et retour également sur l'action menée à
magny les hameaux
nelson mandela s'était un l'âge de 95
ans jeudi dernier une semaine nationale
de deuil vient de débuter en afrique du
sud et les témoignages continuent
d'affluer du monde entier pour saluer
l'engagement d'une vie contre les
inégalités raciales à magny les hameaux
les drapeaux sont en berne vous le voyez
en 2005 la ville avait déjà rendu
hommage à nelson mandela nobel de la
paix en 93 en inaugurant un jardin
public à son nom une gerbe de fleurs il
ya d'ailleurs été déposée ce week-end
par la municipalité
un important incendie a donc détruit
cinq commerces du centre commercial des
gâtines dimanche matin à plaisir le feu
qui s'est déclaré au milieu de la nuit
vers 5 heures dans un restaurant avant
de s'étendre olivier maniscalco elodie
moines pour plus de précisions le centre
commercial des gâtines de plaisir ravagé
par un incendie dimanche matin aux
alentours de 5 heures le feu a fait
irruption dans le restaurant indien du
centre très vite il s'est propagé aux
autres commerces
le coiffeur la boucherie le cabinet
d'experts comptables et la boulangerie
plus de 50 pompiers ont été mobilisés
pour maîtriser le violent incendie
moi j avais le matin 6 heures du matin
pour eux enfin cette heure plus
exactement pour aller chercher du pain
et puis j'ai constaté que c'était
c'était comme ça à peu près dans cet
état là mais il y avait quelques femmes
quand même qu'ils sortaient et quand
même dire que quelques femmes qui
sortaient pour moi j'étais en voiture
chez moi c'est pas sûr descendus sur
plaisir pour pour aller chez mon père
shahi vers 12h et puis bah il y avait
pas mal de camions de pompiers et tous
j'ai pas vu le commerçant mais par part
contre hui les gens étaient choqués le
sinistre important se chiffrera à
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
mais avant le passage des experts
d'assurances l'heure est pour le moment
à lenquête ce matin tous les commerçants
étaient entendus par la police
des commerçants choqué dont certains
évoquent déjà la thèse de l'acte
prémédité
apparemment le feu s'est embrasée très
rapidement et on nous a prévenu vers 7
heures du matin donc voilà on est arrivé
là et on a eu cette catastrophe
apparemment ça serait des départs de
feux de poubelles mais on le voit
autrement on voit qu'il ya des poubelles
brûlées juste en dessous des coursives
donc des poubelles n'avait rien à faire
là
suppose sans ces suppositions des
suppositions que la mairie de plaisir
préfère nuancer en restant plus mesuré
criminels charmant qui est un peu fort
très souvent pour pouvoir il faut déjà
avoir des preuves
moi je suis pas policier donc je peux
espérer que ça soit passe à espérer que
ce soit effectivement une maladresse ou
ou quelque chose d'irréel
exceptionnellement a prévu mais j'y
prends pas non un service de sécurité
est déjà sur place pour protéger le
matériel laissé sur le site
une cellule psychologique va être mis en
place par la mairie pour accompagner les
commerçants après cet épisode douloureux
au minimum huit mois de travaux seront
nécessaires avant la réouverture des
boutiques
en attendant pour permettre aux
commerçants de continuer les ventes en
cette période de fêtes des algécos des
chalets de bois pourrait être installé
sur le parking du centre commercial
si vous empruntez les transports en
commun plus particulièrement la ligne
aile à versailles vous rencontrer sans
doute des difficultés pour vous déplacer
en raison de nombreux dysfonctionnements
ce lundi matin la conseillère régionale
valérie pécresse en présence de
plusieurs élus de droite dont le maire
de versailles françois de mazières se
sont rendus à la gare rive droite
opérations de tractage pour demander à
la région de proposer un plan
pluriannuel d'investissement sur les
infrastructures les élus de
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
viennent eux de voter une motion de
soutien aux quelques deux cent
quatre-vingt dix mille usagers
quotidiens
les patrons d'entreprises et notamment
du secteur du bâtiment en colère et très
inquiets dans le cadre d'un mouvement
unitaire regroupant à la fédération du
bâtiment la cgpme la chambre des métiers
est l'unique syndicat d'auto école ils
ont été reçus ce matin par le préfet le
sujet de catherine plateau et on en
reparle juste après avec nos invités sur
ce plateau
réunis autour d'une même table et
parlant d'une même voix ses
représentants yvelinois de la fédération
du bâtiment de la cgpme ou de la chambre
des métiers réclame des règles claires
plus de lisibilité dans les actions du
gouvernement et une pérennité des
décisions
alors que d'entreprises qui vu le climat
freine les investissements n'embauchent
pas alors qu'ils pourraient le faire et
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
recréer un climat de confiance les
jeunes entreprises si vous voulez ne
savent pas quelles sont les nouvelles
taxes qui vont sortir les lois l'art et
autres rétroactivité des lois
donc on joue un jeu sans avoir la règle
du jeu donc on joue plus il ya un
ras-le-bol de la part de nos adhérents
un d entreprise quelle qu'elle soit
aussi bien petit que moyenne que
importante sur toutes les charges qui
sont promus d'une manière incohérences
c'est à dire que vous voyez nous sommes
le le 10 décembre la tva on ne sait pas
exactement avec quelles modalités
s'appliquent et le 1er janvier c'est le
conte pénibilité qu'il a à mon avis le
la chose la plus grave pour 2014 puisque
nous allons devoir remplir une fiche de
paie de pénibilité par personne et par
jour
en cause également la loi sur la
délocalisation du personnel les fameux
salariés détachés en examen en ce moment
au parlement européen
en france ils étaient 2000 il ya 15 ans
et aujourd'hui ils seraient plus de
200000 le patronat parle de concurrence
déloyale et demande des règles on peut
pas revenir sur la loi de la libre
circulation mais il ya des barrières qui
peuvent être exigés par exemple que les
salariés soient bien déclaré paye bien
les charges sociales dans leur pays
d'origine et bien des congés payés
travaillent avec des heures
supplémentaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
on s'aperçoit que
ce qu'on nous offre c'est des gens qui
travaillent 50 70 heures par semaine
ce mouvement unitaire du patronat
évinois été reçue par le préfet depuis
le mois de septembre
autre signe inquiétant selon eux on voit
de plus en plus d'entreprises
expérimentés affichant dix ans
d'ancienneté fermer boutique
on ne peut pas accepter de se faire tuer
sans rien dire a prévenu je n'y ai je
reçois donc à présent daniel taravella
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
fédération française du bâtiment dans le
département des yvelines et catherine
mutel bonsoir secrétaire général de la
cgpme la confédération générale du
patronat des petites et moyennes
entreprises dans le département cette
réunion ce matin qui était évoquée au
cours du reportage avec le préfet s'est
déroulée comme ans quel bilan vous en
faites ville encore trop tôt pour en
tirer un bilan mais ce que nous pouvons
dire c'est que nous avons été très bien
accueillis par mme augier le préfet à
cette réunion donc il y avait la cgpme
la fédération française du bâtiment la
chambre de commerce et la chambre de
métiers qui étaient des métiers qui
étaient représentés donc nous avons un
petit peu exposé notre façon de voir des
choses à savoir qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
grosse urgence puisque nos petites doses
entreprises sont en grosse difficulté et
qu'il convenait tout de même de faire
quelque chose pour essayer de les aider
en sortir dans la mesure où nous avons
nos adhérents qui nous pousse de plus en
plus à avoir peut-être des actions un
peu plus violentes
vous savez que aussi bien la cgpm que la
fédération du bâtiment nous sommes
plutôt partisan de la concertation et
nous souhaiterions pouvoir avancer dans
la concertation
c'était un premier avertissement ce
matin cette réunion ont eux on peut dire
cela si vous en attendiez quoi
concrètement justement parce que le
préfet reçoit vous écoute
mais derrière c'est pas le préfet qui va
prendre des mesures non banus que nous
attendons c'est que monsieur le préfet
façon remonter nos doléances et nos
explications et nos demandes de mesures
à prendre de façon à ce que lui qui nous
assia qui nous a écouté avec attention
puisse faire en sorte que nous soyons
entendus un peu plus haut et que en
retour nous amuse vous apportez nous
ayons effectivement quelques
améliorations vous disiez tout à l'heure
vous étiez nombreux à participer à cette
réunion avec elle le préfet pourquoi ce
mouvement conjoint on va développer un
petit peu vos revendications juste après
mais déjà pourquoi un mouvement conjoint
pourquoi tous s'allier pour parce que
parce que nous sommes tous conscients
quelles que soient les organisations
nous sommes tous conscients que les
problèmes existent et qu'il convient d'y
remédier au plus tôt et je crois que
c'est l'une des rares fois où nous avons
présenté effectivement un front uni
c'est meilleur moyen de se faire
entendre
voilà c'est pour ça que vous avez six
des sept cette union on revient sur ses
revendications justement aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation
quel constat vous faites pour la cgpme
pour ces les entrepreneurs ces petites
de cette petite entreprise
alors effectivement le constat est pas
formidable puisque comme vous l'avez lu
dans la presse et c'est une réalité et
c'est une réalité qu'on constate sur le
terrain nos entreprises souffre d'une
pression fiscale absolument
insupportable qui font opposition 30 100
% environ
en ce qui concerne la france alors
l'argent alors que ces 20 6% le taux
d'imposition sur les sociétés pour 23%
en moyenne sur l'europe c'est énorme on
a le taux d'imposition plus fort voilà
il sent que quelque part les déficits
publics ne baisse donc nos chefs
d'entreprise se pose aussi des questions
tout cet argent comment est il utilisé
ils ont des problèmes de compétitivité
on décompte problème de baisse de
chiffre d'affaires ils paient ils sont
assommés par les taxes et on a
l'impression que rien ne se passe comme
l' opinion publique perçoit cette
situation en particulier nous avons
voulu savoir si vous pensiez que les pme
ces petites entreprises étaient trop
taxé ce que vous en pensiez vos
sentiments sur la question voici
quelques réponses micro trottoir oui je
pense que les petites entreprises sont
trop taxés et ne peuvent plus employés
et que ça nuit à l'aa à l'emploi est
tout à fait et pas que les petites
entreprises qui sont taxés ouais je
pense que sont trop taxiway parce qu'on
me prend à moi est ce que pas trompé une
monnaie que ça tombe dans la poche
j'aurai un pouvoir d'achat autres quoi
les charges sont vraiment exorbitantes 1
je veux dit moi personnellement dans
l'immédiat j'aurais bien voulu embaucher
une personne est malheureusement à cause
des charges je ne peux pas à embaucher
sept personnes sont énormément taxé
aujourd'hui en france c'est ce qui fait
aussi que justement elles ont du mal à
survivre donc sûr que ça serait bien de
pouvoir changer et diminue un peu ces
taxes qui sont qui sont parfois
violentes pour ces petites entreprises
qui essaient de survivre à pour être
taxés oui ça c'est sûr en casse un petit
peu le les envies des gens les ceux qui
ont envie d'entreprendre
c'est difficile tout le monde se plaint
ça c'est sûr trop taxés je ne sais pas
oui quand même peut-être un peu quand
même avec les augmentations d'impôts et
les charges que les entreprises
supportent où je pense
globalement l'opinion publique qui vous
soutient et qui comprend cette
revendication les petites entreprises
sont trop taxés quels sont les signes
sur le terrain justement de ces
difficultés de ces entrepreneurs on voit
des entreprises qui ferment on entendait
tout à l'heure dans le reportage de
catherine zula tôt que les entreprises
expérimentent et fermer boutique
aujourd'hui dix ans d'ancienneté pour
une entreprise c'est plus forcément gage
de bonne santé
l'année dernière mon en nombre en nombre
il y avait plus de dépôt de bilan
l'année dernière entre le 1er janvier et
le mois d'octobre qui mit en à cette
année mais si l'on veut si l'on examine
la nature les des entreprises on
s'aperçoit excellent qui dépose
actuellement le bilan ce sont des
entreprises déjà beaucoup plus
structurée qui lui qui vont facilement
au moins une dizaine ou une quinzaine de
salariés est effectivement qui ont une
ancienneté supérieure à 5 ans voire 10
ans et ce qui n'était pas le cas
précédemment
et il y à un autre phénomène que j'avais
déjà si que j'avais déjà constaté mois
au sein de la fédération du bâtiment
mais qui a été aujourd'hui confirmée par
la cgpme c'est que nombre d'entreprises
au lieu de chercher à être rachetés ou
continuer ma demande tout simplement dit
je m'arrête et je mets la clé sous la
porte parce que parce qu'il y en a marre
de ces entreprises disparaissent moins
deux reprises d'entreprise moins de
créations aussi j'imagine une création
oui bien sûr donc c'est bien
symptomatique là d'un mal être
les entrepreneurs n'ont pas confiance il
ya une perte de alors ça c'est un point
que nous avons abordé effectivement ce
matin il ya une vraie perte de confiance
de nos chefs d'entreprise et tous les
secteurs sont touchés par ce que votre
mouvement et conjoint vous représentez
la fédération du bâtiment est aussi
l'unique est un syndicat d'auto-école
même constat aussi pour les autres pire
encore peut-être puisque la
représentante indiqué que depuis 2002
elle subissait les effets de la crise
mais très très lourdement armés faisant
vos propositions vos attentes
aujourd'hui stoppée stopper cette
pression fiscale avoir un petit peu plus
de stabilité
il faut se mettre à la place d'un chef
d'entreprise monsieur tarabella vous
serez d'accord avec nous voilà le matin
il ya une annonce
le soir les controversés il n'y a pas de
visibilité à nos chefs d'entreprise ne
peuvent pas anticiper ce qu'il
n'anticipe pas à pointer du doigt c'est
le manque de cohérence non les choses
sont annoncés contestation dans la rue
et voilà on revient en arrière alors
s'il faut il fait qu'ils ont de la
violence pour être écouté c'est un peu
dommage c'est pas effectivement notre
notre volonté un du tout du tout mais
pour prendre un exemple concret qui pour
tout le monde a parlé c'est l'écotaxe
bon l'éco taxe qui devait entrer en
vigueur au 1er octobre si je ne m'abuse
donc le nombre d'entrepreneurs se sont
précipités pour faire équiper leurs
véhicules
ensuite on leur annonce ce sera le 1er
janvier 2014 et puis aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas trop ce qu'il en est donc ces
entreprises qui ont dépensé de l'argent
qu'ils ont investi parce que ça coûte
quand même quelque chose qui ont investi
pour récupérer leur véhicule bas
maintenant sont là avec avec leur
équipement qu'il aurait sur les bras
donc c'est un exemple entendre entre
autres
nous ce qui nous gêne aussi au niveau du
dos et des entreprises va je crois que
c'est vrai pour tout le monde mais
également pour les autres surtout pour
les entreprises du bâtiment
c'est qu'actuellement il y as en
discussion au parlement en examen un
projet de loi qui tend à diminuer de
nouveau le délai de paiement des
fournisseurs d'une quinzaine de jours
alors que les délais clients ne cessent
de s'allonger puisque aujourd'hui en
marché public pour parler de quelque
chose que je connais bien en marché
public où le délai contractuel est
serait normalement de 30 jours
là les collectivités locales payent
couramment 1 60 voire à 90 ou 120 jours
contre et que 30 40 jours pour pouvoir
payer les factures moins une rencontre
en ligne à l'âge de 13 ans et pour ce
qui est des établissements hospitaliers
nous en sommes actuellement à 180 jours
de délai de paiement
juste pour conclure en deux mots quelle
sera la suite du mouvement vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure nous n'aimons pas
aller dans la rue manifester nous faire
entendre trop bruyamment mais si jamais
il fallait nous ferions telle sera la
suite nous avons aussi des chefs
d'entreprises qui commencent à un petit
peu à se mobiliser aussi quelque part
hier
ils attendent aussi qu'il se passe
quelque chose donc
ils sont pris un petit peu par
l'ambiance pêcheries constate que les
bonnets rouges ou les baladins apporte
une couleur quelque chose aura
effectivement on nous dit pourquoi pas
nous mais en l'état je pense que ce que
nous allons faire c'est attendre le
retour de notre visite de ce matin
monsieur le préfet puis à partir de là
je pense que nous aviserons
merci d'avoir les deux je peux vous
citer un chiffre quand même les
importants plus de 61 mille entreprises
ferment 160 par jour et tous les emplois
qui vont avec ça vaut peut-être la peine
quand même des se mobiliser merci à vous
deux je rappelle donc mis les dégâts
sion unitaire du patronat des yvelines
ce matin a été reçue par le préfet pour
faire part de cette situation difficile
que vous évoquez des artisans et des
entrepreneurs
mais le téléthon à l'heure des comptes
plus de 78 millions d'euros de promesses
de dons au 36 37 c'est un peu moins que
les 80 millions de l'an passé sur le
terrain dans les yvelines les animations
ne manquaient pas si les comptes ne sont
pas encore arrêtées la tendance serait
en revanche à la hausse nous vous
dévoilerons les chiffres demain avec le
responsable de la coordination du
département qui sera sur ce plateau mais
nous partons déjà pour magny les hameaux
une commune qui régulièrement bat des
records en matière de solidarité yolaine
13 est muté à gérer ambiance country à
magny les hameaux
vingt associations il centaine de
bénévoles étaient mobilisés ce samedi
pour une seule et même cause
lutter contre les maladies rares ça fait
avancer la recherche
et bien sûr on a tous espoir a
effectivement qu'on fasse des
découvertes qui permet de garder
de guérir ses enfants c'est une bonne
journée les enfants aiment bien
participer ils font des activités moi je
vais faire une démo d'agility avec les
chiens voilà donc on essaye de faire
comme on peut une petite dit action pour
le téléthon jean luc ettori ancien
footballeur de l'as monaco et
international de l'équipe de france
était le parrain de l'événement on n'est
pas à l'abri de tout ça j'ai aussi des
enfants
j'ai de la famille donc voilà à partir
de là et puis si le fait d'avoir je
dirais une petite notoriété fait avancer
et faire avancer les choses
bien sûr qu'on répond présent
l'association objectif téléthon manie
quoi à l'origine de l'événement proposé
des spectacles toutes les demi-heures et
de multiples activités
huit ans après sa création la
mobilisation est toujours aussi forte
c'est grâce à à matoury copains c'est
une grande famille mais miyamoto mes
copains qui participent à tous ces
bénévoles les enfants qui viennent nous
rejoindre
et puis surtout les résultats
significatifs qui nous donne envie de
continuer
l'intégralité des sources récolter
environ dix neuf mille euros est
directement reversée à l'association
française contre les myopathies
et le bilan dans le département donc ce
sera demain dans le journal de 18h en
direct
il est l'heure de faire ses emplettes de
noël et pour certains les cadeaux seront
solidaires justement emmaüs à trappes a
organisé une grande vente en un week end
la structure va réaliser le chiffre
d'affaires d'un mois un argent
indispensable pour faire vivre la
structure qui reçoit de plus en plus de
demandes d aides sociales catherine
château et patrick jacques de dixmude
j'ai acheté des petites choses pour mes
petits enfants
ça fait de la musique et tout et tout
4 oignons et locomotives
j'ai fait un peu des emplettes de noël
voilà de très beaux bijoux en un
week-end de grande vente solidaire la
boutique emmaüs de trappes a reçu
jusqu'à mi clients et réaliser ainsi en
deux jours le produit d'un mois de
ventes
ici on trouve toutes sortes d'objets des
prix défiant toute concurrence et il va
ch mont-joli quoi il n'est pas abîmée
j'ai payé un euro
et il ya plein de choses sur wii qui
décide et je le dis même pas mes amis
parce qu'il me croirais pas pour les
fêtes le responsable du centre a reçu
des dons importants les grandes
entreprises sont de plus en plus
solidaire on a reçu un don très
important de jouets électroniques qui
plaît bien aux enfants d'une valeur
assez importantes de 50 euros et qui est
revendue 10 euros en est à 9 à la fois
de la solidarité des grandes entreprises
aujourd'hui qui avait pas hier et puis
les dons qui pour nous sont quand même
très important en terme de vêtements en
particulier des dons et donc des ventes
de l'argent emmaüs on a besoin car la
structure ne reçoit aucune subvention
pour payer ses charges et mener à bien
ses actions de solidarité accueillir les
personnes sans domicile fixe ou encore
partager des repas avec ceux qui n'ont
rien c'est indispensable
parce qu'on a on a eu un temps de
réponse immédiate c'est-à-dire là si la
personne est dans le besoin ou on peut
répondre tout de suite sans faire des
dossiers sans sans lourdeur
administrative depuis deux ans laurent
robert l'a constaté les demandes aide
sociale d'urgence ont progressé de 30%
le verdict pour les participants à la
dernière ligne droite du concours axe
apollo space academy lancé par une
grande marque de déodorant il a déjà
permis à une vingtaine de chanceux de
par le monde dont 5 français de se
retrouver à cap canaveral en floride
pendant une semaine pour subir des tests
d'astronautes et il n'y aura finalement
pas dit blinois ils étaient deux en
course pourtant
mais ni le représentant des
clayes-sous-bois ni celui d'orphelin ne
l'emportent ils auront tout de même
franchi le mur du son la semaine
dernière en avion de chasse et survécu à
la terrible épreuve de la centrifugeuse
très à la mode chez les filles le roller
derby est un sport très spectaculaire
qui vient des états unis les règles deux
équipes sur patins à roulettes
s'affrontent un corps à corps est
découverte avec les succubes premier
club des yvelines anthony rech et
patrick jacques de dixmude pour cette
découverte
spectacle tenues extravagantes vitesse
une chose est sûre les filles du roller
derby n'ont peur de rien sur leurs
patins à roulettes le contact et souvent
violents les chutes très fréquentes
effectivement il ya un petit côté
déjanté
il y en a plusieurs qui ont des cheveux
de couleur les piercings les tatouages
c'est un sport qui est assez rock c'est
assez décalé moi j'avais envie de
reprendre un sport de combat au départ
et en même temps c'était trop
disciplinés pour moi
là il ya de la musique il ya de la
plaisir de la glisse et il ya le plaisir
de se mettre des coups aussi bas après
on va voir en direct les copies des
tribunes cela pourrait ressembler à une
énorme mêlée pourtant la règle du jeu
est très simple la jammeuse doté d'une
étoile sur le casque doit marquer des
points en dépassant les bloqueuses de
l'équipe adverse
prête à tout pour la faire chuter
le roller derby c'est aussi l'occasion
idéale d'oublier à la mode américaine
les complexes et le quotidien pour les
filles le défouloir c'est super
important
c'est un sport de filles avant tout donc
elles ont besoin de s'exprimer
voilà sur le trac sur la piste qui après
quand elle rentre s'occupe de la petite
famille on a beaucoup de mères de
famille même si on n'est pas forcément
déjanté à l'extérieur on devient ici
peuvent par l'esprit par le sport
d'équipé puis c'est un sport américain
donc et à tous tout un peu un show
américain autour et à ça permet aussi
justement nous externalisés pour leur
premier match officiel face aux mille
roller girl des succubes ne l'ont pas
emporté mais nul doute qu'elles
continueront encore longtemps de se
battre sur l'euro l' arrêt pour le point
complet sur le sport tous les sports 1
vous l'avez vu et puis les principaux
résultats du week end rendez vous dès 18
heures 35 l'année avec un anthony rech
pour le 7-8 sport pour terminer ce
journal voici les images du nouveau site
internet de la base de loisirs de
trappes plus lisible plus accessible il
vous permettra d'aller à l'essentiel que
vous soyez un particulier ou que vous
veniez en groupe ou encore avec votre
entreprise on notera les prochains
évènements de ce parc régional elle
dimanche 22 décembre centre équestre les
jeux de noël et les lundis 23 et 30
décembre à la ferme pédagogique des
ateliers de découverte sensorielle
tous les détails sont bien sûr en ligne
bases de loisirs 78 point fr le journal
revient à mardi 18h en direct je vous
retrouverai aussi demain 18h30 pour une
nouvelle édition de municipales 2014
avec l'ump
marc robert qui tentera de succéder à
gérard larcher à rambouillet et puis
également le socialiste didier fischer
candidats à coignières actuellement
conseiller municipal d'opposition
bonne soirée sans notre antenne